so we're I'm very happy to have Peter
Schultz speaking here today he's an
assistant professor at ours and he's
been working a lot on MPC and it's sort
of crossed over into lattices a bit so
this would be a very nice talk about the
intersection of these two very
interesting fields and so go ahead great
thanks very much for the introduction
video yes so I'll be telling you about
an application of lattice based
cryptography to multi-party computation
in the form of the speeds protocol for
MPC so this talk is not so much about
some current research of mine it's more
of a general survey of the area covering
several different works and i'd like to
quickly acknowledge caster in my cell as
the thanks for some discussions which i
think helped form some of the insights
are present okay so the rough plan for
today is to take you on a little journey
of speeds so starting with some
background on where it fits into MPC
what kinds of tools it users and then
moving on to describing the protocols so
both look at a simplified passively
secure version of the protocol before
moving on to the full protocol with
active security which uses some more
complex techniques like zero knowledge
proof and then the last chunk of this
talk will be dedicated to looking at
some open questions in the area in
particular few directions which I think
might be interesting and relevant for
people working in space cryptography
okay so we're doing MVC multi-party
computation where we have a bunch of
parties with some private inputs and
they want to securely compute some
function say F across their private
inputs do this while just learning the
output of the function and nothing else
on the inputs
okay so within the world of MPC which is
I'm sure you aware a very large area we
have a lot of different types of
protocols so speeds is a protocol in the
dishonest majority setting so this is
one of the strongest corruption settings
were up to n minus one out of n parties
might be corrupt
any pointers protocol this requires
computational assumptions you can't do
things information theoretically like
with an honest majority and additionally
if you want active security you're
limited in this case security with a
board and no fat so the corrupt set of
parties can enforce the protocol to
terminate so that no honest probably
learned the output ok the computational
model we'll be looking at is securely
computing arithmetic circuits quite
straightforward he will consider the
usually a finite field say the integers
modulo large prime although there are
also variants of speeds which can handle
different things like boolean circuits
or computations of more general rings
and just so I get it out the way the
original speeds protocol is based on
this paper by dangled Posterous Martin's
at Korea's from 2012 this was already
building on some ideas from a previous
protocol this Pedrosa work from 2011 and
then the of course with many subsequent
developments in the area and variations
on this some of which I'll talk more
about in detail later and it's it's kind
of the whole line of work which I refer
to when I talk about speeds itself not
specifically the original paper and I'm
going to try and cover as much as I can
are given there's only now many
apologies if there are some important
works or works of your own which I
didn't manage to come here ok so speed
is a protocol in what we call the
pre-processing model in MPC where the
protocol is divided into two phases
first we have a pre-processing phase
which you can think of as an ideal
functionality which samples some
correlated randomness and gives each
party one private portion of this
correlated randomness so here each party
just gets this random string
alright and then these are used in the
online phase of the protocol together
with the inputs of the parties where
they interact or should learn the
results of the computation so in
practice the parties actually have to
run some interactive protocol to do this
pre-processing phase but the advantage
is first
can be done in advance of the
computation and secondly doing this
separation means that the online phase
can be very very efficient so it's very
lightweight it's almost entirely
information theoretic primitives that
are used and the computational cost is
only around a factor of two on top of
computing the arithmetic circuit in the
clear that's if you have no
communication but still very cheap okay
so the main tool we use in speeds this
is mainly in the online phase is
additive secret sharing with information
theoretic max this is a very simple kind
of information thread at max scheme
where we pick a random at key which is
just a random field element and set P
and then to compute a Mac on X we just
take X and multiply it with the secret
key modulo P so technically speaking I
should say this isn't actually a Mac it
you can save more of an AMD code or
something but it's essentially used as
as a Mac in the protocol so we call it a
Mac okay and then the secret sharing
scheme that is used based on this is
just additive secret sharing combined
with the Mac's so whenever some value X
is secret shared in the protocol this
means we have X together with the Mac on
X and also the secret key or additively
secret shared between the end parties
and I use this angle brackets notation
to denote the one of these values is
added to be shared so each probably
holds some share X I which sums together
in the field to give you X okay so once
we have some secret shared values and
speeds we need a way to be able to
reconstruct them so then anything would
be to just open the shares of X and
reconstruct X then you want some way of
actually checking with Mac relation and
the main challenge is to do this in a
way with where so you can check the Mac
without revealing the Mac key itself
because as soon as someone learns the
Mackay then they can forge a Mac at any
stage later in the protocol but you
don't want to happen
so the way this is done is to to first
open X and this is just sending the
shares to everyone else and
reconstructing them so there could be
some additive error say Delta here and
then each party will compute this extra
value called di here where I'm going to
multiply my share of the Maki alpha with
the value that's been opened X and then
subtract from this my share of the Mac
on X now if you look at what happens
when you sum all these di things
together then if the max were correct we
should just getting alpha times X minus
the original max so we get 0 so the
party's going to just open all that
commitments sum these up and check that
this gives 0 okay so why did the exactly
give us and way of opening the max why
can like in a party not cheat well
suppose we have this error Delta in the
original opening of X then when you
compute this sum on all of the D values
what this error translates to is an
error multiplied by the Mac key because
you have alpha times X Prime and since
we're in a large finite fields if an
adversary can come up with some corrupt
di to make this match check pass then
they must have guessed alpha times Delta
and the only way they can do this is by
guessing alpha this is about where we
assumed that they were in a field and
we're in a large finite field there are
ways to work around these two things but
I won't go into that now ok so now we
have the information theoretic max
secret sharing and opening we're ready
for the main part of the online phase
which is evaluating this arithmetic so
good so for every wire in the circuit
we're going to have this invariant where
the value X that corresponds to the wire
has been additively seeker shared with
these max because everything is linear
the max of linear the share the linear
if you want to do additions or
multiplications by a constant then you
could just do this locally so main
challenge where you have to rely on the
pre-processing phase is in
multiplication gates so suppose we have
seeker of values x and y which
additively shares and just ignoring the
max for the moment it doesn't make a
difference there and then what we need
for the pre-processing is what we call a
multiplication triple so it sees three
shared values a B and the private
product of a and B which is used to
multiply x and y so we'll first mask an
open inputs x and y with a and b values
of the triple these are just random so
this isn't going to leak anything about
x and y and then i'm gonna write this
product relation in a slightly different
way by adding some terms which are 0 to
both sides and then expanding the result
you get something a little ugly but if
you are if you highlight some of the
terms here then it makes a bit more
sense what I'm doing so everything
that's in blue here is what we opened
previously the X plus a and y plus B
values then everything that's in red on
the right of these a and B and a time B
shares which we have from the
preprocessor so then this is all veneer
in the secret values on the right so we
can just use the operations on the
linear shares to compute the shares of x
times y after we've done these two
openings so multiplication gates do you
need one triple from the pre-processing
and then two openings and that's
basically the entirety of the online
face there's one part I've missed down
which is how you actually create these
shared values at the input layers to
begin with that needs a little more from
the people saying but it's quite
straightforward and I won't go into that
now ok so do we have any questions
before I move on ok I will assume no
it's great so let's move on to this
pre-processing phase let's record we
have this idea of functionality
generating the triples which we want to
realize giving these shares of a ibi in
CI to each of the parties so our two
main approaches to doing this in speeds
like protocols based on
Wolfgang Krypton one of them is a
slightly earlier bird OSA methods and
mentioned earlier which actually uses
literally a morphic encryption then
relies on pairwise communication between
every pair of parties to generate the
triples in a pairwise manner the speeds
approach is a little different it uses
depth 1 multiplicative homomorphic
encryption and all of the communication
is very broadcast channel and even
though the asymptotic complexity is the
same in practice it tends to scale
better with the number of parties
whereas Padova can be a little bit
faster for two or three parties in some
cases I'm going to talk about the speeds
approach here of course okay so the main
tool we use is a homework encryption
scheme with this threshold property so
here we have some algorithms keygen
encryption and distributive decryption
we actually both the key generation and
distributed decryption will be
interactive protocols and the scheme has
a plaintext basis that PP is the modulus
for the arithmetic circuit we want to
compute I had a bit more notation here
I'll have these square brackets to
denote encryptions of a plaintext value
a so we need this scheme to be some more
fake where we just need a linear number
of additions in the number of parties
and one multiplication on ciphertext and
we have a keygen protocol which creates
some setup where we have a common public
key known to all of the parties and then
a secret key which is additively secret
shares where everybody has some share
say si the secret SK and the
distribution protocol which takes this
key set up together with the ciphertext
and then it's a protocol the parties run
so they can recover the original message
okay and today I'm just going to focus
on the rest of the scheme but not the
key generation setup
okay so we can instantiate this from
basically any lattice based encryption
scheme using LD a ring lwe they all have
the right properties we need for this so
what most papers uses some variant of
PGV or kind of standard ring out the
vewy based encryption scheme by now so
we work over this polynomial ring which
is polynomials of the integers modulo X
to the n plus 1 where N is a power of
two so it's a to power cycle atomic as
well as the plaintext modulus P we have
a cycle ciphertext modulo Q there has
some small distribution as the sample
script key in samaritans from the
plaintext base is going to be the ring
are reduced modulo P and if we choose
the parameters carefully then we can use
this Chinese remainder theorem to
decompose R P so that it's a direct
product giving a 10 copies of Zed P so
this means the plant x place is not that
P itself but it's actually vectors of
length n over said P key generation
algorithm this is the basic key
generation not the actual protocol
I will sample a public key which is just
bringing lwe sample so random a and
their B which is a times S Plus a scaled
multiple times by P of some small error
term and then the secret K is a secret
ass let me write the public key in this
form B minus a just to simplify things a
little later okay then encryption that
the details are less important here but
basically to encrypt a message mu we
take the public key and then you've
reran demise it using bring lwe again
where if we multiply the public key by
some small number you which is kind of
like another secret key and add it on
some noise turns and add it on the
message to one
entries then decryption equation is more
important here to decrypt the ciphertext
C 0 C 1 we can compute C 0 plus C 1
times a secret key and if you work it
out what this gives you is the message
with some additive noise term which has
been multiplied by P so we just reduces
mod Peterik of the message ok so because
the linearity of decryption this has
immediately linear hole morphism so we
can do some additions which is what we
want and then we can also get one
multiplication from this directly if we
allow a small amount of ciphertext
expansion the nicest way to see this is
by viewing the ciphertext as a
polynomial so the C 0 plus C 1 times by
X that should be and then you decrypt
this by evaluating the polynomial with
the secret key so that means if you want
to multiply two ciphertext you would
just multiply polynomials now you get a
degree 2 polynomial instead of degree 1
polynomials with the caveat that now the
decryption procedure
additionally requires knowledge of s
squared so in this key generation set up
were actually gonna require additive
shares of s as well as additive shares
of s squared if we want to do
distributed diversion ok so then the
distribution caption protocol it's
suppose we have a ciphertext which here
is just a kind of input level ciphertext
they haven't been multiplied and we want
to decrypt it the kind of naive thing to
do is okay we can just compute this
linear operation in the secret key we
have shares of s the ciphertext is
public and then we can open this the
problem here of course is when you look
at this we have this noise term be prime
here and this noise I keep depends on
the secret key no one knows the secret
key we do we don't want to reveal some
information about this to the parties so
the naive solution here is to use this
noise driving technique which
into some of the other talks this week
you've probably seen this in other
contexts where you you know you're gonna
drown out this small error e Prime with
a much larger error by adding on P times
by a shared value e tilde which is going
to be super polynomial e larger than the
maximum value of the e prime noise we're
trying to hide so to do that each party
can just say sample locally some
sheriffing tilde and then add this up
when revealing the cipher text well in
practice you need this to be about say
at two to the forty or two to the 64
times bigger than the noise band of your
cipher text okay so how do we use this
to generate multiplication triples well
given all these things the basic
protocol is pretty straightforward
so each party is just going to sample
some random messages AI bi CI Prime I'm
calling you here just to differentiate
from C which comes later and then
broadcast encryptions of each of these
shares
then all parties will take the
ciphertext and add them out to be some
krypton's of a B and C prime using the
homework operation then we'll multiply a
and B together again with Hamas awesome
and then subtract the encrypted value C
prime which the parties generated in the
first place and what this gives us is
sum from Delta between the original C
Prime shares they generated and the
actual product of the real shares a and
B then we run the distributed decryption
on this shared Delta and that allows the
parties to then adjust the original
random shares they sampled to lead you
to a correct additive sharing of a
multiplication triple so actually the
only party who needs to change anything
is say party P one who just takes a c1
prime share adds on Delta they just
assume they have a correctable so this
is a kind of passive protocol without AG
max if you want to add the max then you
can essentially do the same procedure
where the parties the
already have the ciphertext encrypting
the shares of the triple from the first
phase so you just need an encryption of
the Mac key then you did the same
multiplication followed by distributive
decryption okay so that's the simplified
version of speeds once you have the
threshold term of corruption that should
be straightforward do we have any
questions
I'm Peter can I ask you the question
yeah sure so things you are encrypting
those are your triples basically you'll
be using an online phase and each one is
only used once yes yes that's right
so each so even if you leak something I
would sort of not super that's roughly
it I mean I sort of okay I don't see
what but it's not super catastrophic if
you leak a little bit or maybe you can
drown with a little less improve coming
on to something which I'm gonna talk a
bit more about at the end but just to
quickly say now it I'm not sure whether
you're talking about leaking on the
secret key or leaking on the triples
themselves I assumed you might the
secret key right let's see yeah yeah
because in the online phase yes because
if you have a triple wet which is not
uniformly random then this will actually
leak information on maybe some of your
inputs in the online phase so so you
really need the triples to be completely
random no leakage but but the secret
maybe you can tolerate something and you
can choose a different secret key for
each encryption right yes yes exactly
yes this is yeah I'll have more on this
later okay okay okay so let's move on to
active security so there's basically two
main changes we need to make to the
passively secure protocol to make the
is actively skill the first one is
adding in zero knowledge proof of
plaintext knowledge so every time a
party broadcast some ciphertext saying
this encryption of AI then I need two
runners or a notch proof where I prove
that I know the underlying message AI
together with the randomness which was
used to encrypt it so this ensures that
all the ciphertext were correctly
generated and nothing can go wrong there
so then we still need to do one more
step on top of there no it proves which
is add some actual verification
procedure to check that the triple some
cells are correct now the reason for
this is that there could be some extra
errors introduced during the distributed
decryption process so recall we we did
this to be descriptions on a b and c and
then we use these shares again to
multiply in the mac key in the second
iteration so it could be that you might
get additive errors in the C term after
we've decrypted which would then be
introduced when you multiply with the
mac key in the next step i was the way
to verify this is just to perform what
we call this sacrifice check where you
take one multiplication triple and then
use it to check the correctness of
another so involves some random
challenge in the field which gives you
some soundness error one over the size
of the field it's basically a factor to
overhead so the main thing of interest
to having care and especially maybe to
this audience is the zero knowledge
proof that are used for the ciphertext
so I'll move on to those a little bit
now so recall the encryption equation we
had this two ring element cipher text
which is encrypted by taking the public
key - ba
multiplying it by some small polynomial
adding some noise then adding the
message okay so we can massage this a
little bit into a nicer looking linear
relation we're on the Left we have a
matrix which because it's at the public
key and some public values in another
right all of the randomness the message
that secret in the cipher
next so what we want to do is just prove
knowledge of some short preimage that
satisfies its linear relation so we have
some known bounds on the sizes of said
the noise terms and the message we want
to verify want to prove that this halts
so thankfully there's a lot of
techniques for doing this that have been
studied over the last few years
mostly building on work of a team and
others they all follow this kind of
standard nor type Sigma protocol
approach with this three move protocol
between approver and verify so if you
want to prove knowledge of the secret
are and the proven the first message
will generate the fresh random cipher
text with different randomness out prior
and the verify responds with random
challenge in this case let's just say
it's binary and the previous sends back
this value Z which is either the
randomness are prime or the sum our
parameters are so then the verify at the
end we'll have to check firstly the dead
is short as we want and secondly that
said satisfy the linear relation which
is going to be defined by a C plus C
prime C prime plus e times C and if this
holds then this should be a good proof
so we have binary challenges which you
can show this this gives you sign as a
half so given to accepting transcripts
you can extract some short witness from
the prover but the more challenging
thing here is that this final values
that you're sending just like the
distributed decryption this might
involve some leakage on the secret
because you're masking our with our
prime it's in the case the equals one
and if these both have the same size and
because they're small and there's no
wrap around them they couldn't leak
something so the two kind of standard
options you can do to address this I
think the rejection sampling which is
kind of complex and adds some
computational overheads but can work
well or you can do the more naive noise
drowning again where you just choose R
prime to be
I mean larger than our the problem with
noise drowning here is this introduces
this soundness slack parameter into the
proof where if you choose R prime to be
very very large then a dishonest prove I
can also choose R to be much louder than
what you want it to be and still pass
the proof this means in your encryption
scheme you need the modulus Q to be much
larger than you would would normally
with the passive protocol and gives you
bigger parameters but in practice if you
look at all of the speeds
implementations out there as far as I
know they all actually follow this noise
drowning approach I think mainly just
because it's simple as they implement
I'm not sure if actually any comparison
between the computational efficiency in
the case of speeds here okay so you can
do some optimizations to this basic
approach a natural one is to go for a
larger challenge space so this this top
gear protocol also building on previous
work from Nvidia min others I choose
those challenges from which the powers
of X instead of just binary will just
gives you some better sound now so means
you don't need any repetitions the
slight thing to watch out for here is
that it doesn't prove that the secret R
is exactly short
it proves that two times R is short it
turns out you can tweak the protocol and
make this work on two speeds that's not
a problem
and then another I think very important
optimization is amortize improves so
with a nave kind of binary challenge
space but even with the powers of X
challenge space you still have to repeat
this proof many times and stand new
ciphertex for each each time you want to
proof yes if you have many cipher texts
you want to prove it once so if you're
creating a very large batch of triples
and with amortization techniques you can
reduce this multiplicative overhead in
the security parameter from repetitions
to just an ad if it out head and so this
greatly reduces your communication
complexity down to just a constant
factor on top of the passive protocol
instead of multiplicative
okay so that's the basic certain launch
proof and the actively secure protocol
now I'm just going to talk about a few
different variations on the general
protocol as I said a lot of different
works which have looked at this and done
things differently
I'll try mention a few of them here
so the firstly this recent work on
ePrint by Howard Chen and others where
they it took speeds and tweaked a few
things about it now they use depth to
somewhat home of corruption instead of
depth one so you actually need two
multiplications to get the Mac key and
what this does is instead of doing a
distributive decryption after the first
multiplication so that you can support
depth one you only do a single one at
the end which means you can avoid the
sacrifice procedure when you generate
triples and you can also use scale
invariant amorphic encryption instead of
bgv there's probably some trade-offs
there I'm not sure about it there at
comparison and you can also use fancy
things like the autumn morphisms and
home wolf encryption schemes to generate
more complex types of proposals and data
like matrix triples for example and
there's another variant of distributed
decryption which I want to mention which
is only applicable to the two party
setting but I think it's quite
interesting instead of having this
interactive protocol with noise drowning
you can just have a local rounding
procedure they were given a ciphertext
and shares of the secret key they were
kind of locally compute the shares of
this decryption and then kind of round
this to get which results in a share of
the message it doesn't recover the
method itself it's not interactive but
you get a share of message and you can
adapt speeds so that you use this
instead one problem with this is it
still needs a super polynomial modulus
even though you don't have noise
drowning you actually get a kind of
correctness error from the rounding if
you don't have a big gap between the
message size and
this comes from spooky encryption
anamorphic secret sharing techniques
finally you can also throw at these key
switching and modular switching
strategies which are often used in fully
homomorphic encryption so I'm not
totally clear about the different
trade-offs with key switching but I
think modular switching can in some
sense reduce the overhead from the
soundness flack and the noise proofs if
you just do noise drowning then if you
modular switch before multiplying that
it reduces the blow-up of this there's
extra soundest like parameter you had in
the modulus so that doesn't become
quadratics of words after multiplying
okay so now I plan to move on to some
open questions and possible directions
unless have any more questions about the
protocol okay so before moving on to the
concrete directions I've been thinking
about I just want to say okay what are
the areas we can hope to actually do
better in this protocol I think one
significant thing is the parameters of
the homework encryption scheme so if you
look at some example parameters you
typically have say plaintext space which
is maybe between 64 and 128 bits and
with all of the noise drowning in the
zero knowledge and just a bit of
decryption procedures this gives you a
modulus of between maybe 300 or up to
600 bits depending on other parameters
and the dimension in the ring is usually
around 16,000 or maybe 32,000 so this is
kind of close to the fhe level of
practice even though we only do one
multiplication then related to this I
think a significant thing of interest is
that the zero knowledge proves plaintext
knowledge so as I said we we have these
amortization techniques but if you want
to get the best out of them then you
need to be creating a large batch of
triples in the first place and since the
cipher texts are already so big like
16,000 or something then
have to repeat this 40 time is to get
efficiently then you're already
generating close to a million trembles
if you don't want to do a batch size
that big then you don't really have any
other option at this point and secondly
these proofs are quite expensive and
told it's about 40 percent of the run
time I think in in some areas it might
actually contribute a lot more so in
particular using these proofs of
knowledge actually means the
communication complexity of this
protocol has to be quadratic in the
number of parties so I didn't mention it
at the time but the passive protocol if
you look at it everything the center of
the network all you're doing is
basically sending some ciphertext
summing them up and then computing the
results so naively that's quadratic but
you can always optimize this by just
sending the cipher text or the shares to
one party terms of the shares locally
and then it sends back only the result
to everybody else so with that the
entire passive protocol can be linear in
the number of parties that's both the
offline and the online favors whereas
here as soon as you throw in zero
knowledge proof switch you need everyone
to be able to verify to ensure no-one's
cheating then we don't see how to avoid
this quadratic blow-up there will be
something nice to avoid Peter yeah so
you're saying you variables in PC sorry
I'd love many of these triples no sorry
how many of these triples do you
typically need to have for your NPCs
okay yes and that really depends on what
you're doing so yeah I think if if
you're doing kind of complex
applications which which have like a lot
of you know maybe not not naturally
arithmetic operations where maybe you
need to mix arithmetic with things like
comparisons or other nonlinear
operations then to do those types of
things like rapidly blows up your
numbers triples and you can easily get
into the millions
but I could also imagine there might be
small a use cases where you just have a
kind of simple single simple task you
wanna do it it might be more like
thousands or tens of thousands but yeah
it very much depends okay thanks okay so
you know so right now we need this noise
flooding or drowning analysis and in the
Zika probes can be used something like
the running divergence type analysis
perhaps it's a number of you know the
number of surfer interactions is small
enough isn't there a better sort of
analysis at this point well it's so I
don't know about any year analysis do
you mean jack by just running the proof
naively with some smaller there's some
smaller drowning noise because you can
always do rejection sampling for the
serology proofs and that reduces this
sounds like but it's a little more
expensive and complicated so so there is
this sort of a line of work of dam Ian
that I believe Damien and France would
say said you know instead of so
analyzing statistical distance between
distributions you can just analyze the
whiny divergence and that's sometimes
good enough for yeah so I don't know if
that can be applied to zeros proofs this
this is also somewhat related to
something I'll come to later but yeah
that I don't know the answer to that
when I have come across these works in
other contexts I'm not sure if you can
use them that ok ok so the yeah the
ideal goal we would like to have for
general it proofs is of course something
where we can get negligible soundness in
just a single execution also getting
tight bounds on the size of the
witnesses now maybe one possible
approach is to use something which
Gregor was talking about the other day
and which of these types of proofs on
committed values also building on
previous works where instead of proving
statements about the ciphertext directly
you can create some commitments all of
the randomness and the message in the
ciphertext prove that these commitments
contain short values and then prove the
commitments together satisfy the linear
relation defined by the ciphertext and
the public key not sure how how much
overhead therapy and additionally
committing to all of this random enough
for every ciphertex you use but it might
be interesting to explore especially if
you're in this kind of small batch size
setting where you don't want to create
as many triples it was like an a million
awesome Andy and if you can also
amortize this in some way so that you
avoid the overhead of creating all these
commitments and that might be very
interesting and what is the objective
that you're trying to minimize here is
it the time or is it the size of the
commitments of the community size of the
proofs the communication complexity what
is the main so if you're in a one-shot
setting then I would say probably
communication complexity although and
it's all kind of important if
computation becomes a big bottleneck
then that's not so good but at least as
far as I know the existing techniques
for proving knowledge of ciphertext
without going via commitments you you
have to do a lot of repetitions and then
the main thing that's that's gonna get
you into trouble there is that massive
amount of communication
yeah so
there's also discovered version of
speeds where they don't use your
knowledge all together and there yes so
what is the difference like of course
it's a covert security but can you
compare in terms of security
practicality I think covert security it
definitely has this nice benefit way if
you want to do it on a small batch size
then you can do things very efficiently
with essentially the overhead is going
to be multiplicative in whatever your
covert parameter is so if you want the
adversary to you only be able to cheat
with probability
ever see you got affected see overhead
in ranked town so I think if you're
happy with that kind of thing and say
with like C equals five or ten that's
definitely a good approach yeah
so that but there they also use
commitments right but they don't prove
yeah it's a bit different okay yeah yeah
and if they it's just regular
commitments no yes base commitments
yes okay thank you okay so I've talked
about maybe improving the serology
proofs but I think one thing that's
interesting to explore is whether we
actually even need these zero knowledge
proof in the first place so they said we
already have this triple verification
procedure which guarantees that what you
have at the end is a correct
multiplication trouble okay so what
could actually go wrong if you just take
out the proofs and then run speed says
it's okay well I thought about this a
little the first thing that goes wrong
is okay sorry I'm getting ahead of
myself here okay so the main challenge
is to ensure that in this verification
step the the failure event of the
correctness check passing or not has to
be independent of any sensitive
information like the secret key of the
underlying messages proving this is very
difficult but I think if you can do
something then you can avoid this
quadratic complexity from the zero
knowledge proof and get better
parameters and the safe attacks because
all of this noise grounding stuff goes
away and you get much less computation
basically the effect or two overhead
over the passive protocol this is kind
of a dream goal which is so kind of
difficult to analyze but slightly
related work here is the overdrive paper
from two years ago where they did
something somewhat similar by removing a
proof of correct multiplication which
was in a different protocol where they
still had proofs of proof of knowledge
of
ciphertex generation but they got rid of
the like the other proof and then proof
security related to some linear only
encryption assumption which has been
used also in lettuce based snog
constructions okay so so the first
problem that comes it comes across if
you do this is you no longer have
independence of inputs so I could just
send a cipher text which is the same as
someone something I received or you know
I can force the cipher text to all be
encryption observer at the end of it
I simply flipping the sign but this is
an easy one to work around with just by
committing to ciphertext and then
opening of all the commitments together
at the end okay so the second problem is
exactly this problem that we're
verifying correctness and this is check
of the triples like yet the outcome of
whether it succeeds or not can be seen
as a kind of decryption Oracle which the
adversary might try to exploit you know
something somewhat analogous to a CCA
attack with a standard lattice based
public key encryption scheme but in
speech is actually much more restricted
compared to a regular CCA
attack so so we have a lot of things we
can we can do to try to mitigate this
and as for demas suggesting earlier you
know if if we do this kind of check and
it fails then the parties can all agree
to just regenerate the keys and an abort
not use something again so this
significantly restricts the adversary
and that every time they kind of try to
use this decryption Oracle type thing
then they have to be guaranteed they're
gonna be passed as soon as they fail
then they lose the game at this point if
they learn something it doesn't actually
matter if we abort because all we're
doing is just random pre-processing
anyway you can also restrict the number
of executions you use for any given
secret key and if you can maybe bound
the leakage in some way from each
possible query then peps you can
increase the entropy and the secret key
to compensate and finally what one thing
you have to take care of is that if
you're leaking anything on the actual
data on the trip was themselves
just a secret key then that's something
that can really cause a problem the
online phase and you don't want so even
if that does occur there are kind of
standard ways you can use to work around
that using something like the leftover
hash lemma as a randomness instructor to
extract entropy from from triples so I
think there's a lot of things to look at
here and to me it doesn't seem like
there's there's that much that can go
wrong from this I think the challenge is
mainly to do with analyzing what does
happen and kind of formally modeling the
type of decryption queries or Oracle
queries in every circuit making this but
I think it seems like a promising
direction bad you could even prove some
kind of security based on some entropic
there and lwe which we actually have
some theoretical hardness results about
I think ok so and the second thing I
will look at is not related to zero
knowledge proof spurred you about the
noise drowning process in the
distributed decryption can I ask you
something with the previous layer yeah
sure so do you need to it's a word
exactly do you need ciphertext and not
just commitments and opening commitments
so is it so it's it's gonna be whenever
so in the first phase of the triple
generation when everyone sends the
encryptions of AI and bi and CI yes so
there they just have to commit to the
ciphertext first and then open the
commitments after everyone has committed
but why do they have to be encryptions
of AI bi and CI why can't they be Jeff
as commitments to them because they
still open them anyway in a distributed
fashion so usually never open the
underlying claim text which you sent to
so I guess if you had somehow morphic
commitment then you could do that right
so
but but I'm just thinking like a simple
you know grand America based commitment
so it's it's not going to add much
complexity on top of what's already done
no I was just thinking that if you
didn't have ciphertex if you only had
commitments then it would be easier to
sort of not leak anything if you don't
do zero knowledge right because you leak
some if it's a statistically hiding
commitment then you leak some part of
the randomness and it's no probably no
problem right so if you mean you replace
the encryption itself with a some kind
of a commitment scheme right I see what
you mean yeah but then you still need to
multiply the underlying shares
themselves right and commitments to that
give you multiplication on the values
not trivially again you have to do some
commitments in particular you can you
can do multiplications but I think the
best of my knowledge that's only known
from sort of like gist of you like
techniques which probably are you know
that they'll didn't take you to a next
level of inefficiency okay yeah yeah it
sounds interesting but I'm I'm not so
familiar with these for morphic
commitment schemes that could do that
okay are there any more questions okay
so the last thing I want to talk about
related to speeds is the disability
corruption which then goes back to the
question earlier about the noise
drowning of the question with the bad
news or knowledge proofs but here I want
to look at it in the distributed
decryption lens where we're doing this
noise trying to mask the noise in the
ciphertext you open so the first
question is is there any approach to
doing this without drowning so we're
covering the message in some way and I
guess you could always do kind of
generic multi-party computation to
decrypt it but that's a bit excessive we
want something simple which recovers M
exactly and then secondly what actually
goes wrong if we just take this approach
and reduce the size of the Drowned nice
so I I don't know if you don't use
something like rainy diversions to
analyze this it might be you can but I
haven't seen anything along these lines
intuitively to me it seemed like a kind
of difficult problem to look at the
exact leakage on the secret key from
this but then also it doesn't seem like
it should be that bad because especially
in this case the secret key has always
been multiplied by some some random
noise term he Prime two different fairy
cipher texts it's not like look like
you're getting some kind of fixed
leakage on every time and every time
this is quirk but I mean this looks like
a kind of tricky thing to analyze and
whether you can do it information
theoretically or do some maybe
computational problem that says that
shows that it's hard to recover the s
given this leakage I don't know but
you'll be great to see something looking
at this problem okay
the last thing I what I mentioned is
actually a different approach to
multiplication triple generation for
speeds which is line of work I've
recently been involved in where we
instead of using home wealth encryption
and you look at a way of generating
triples somehow not interactively so
goal is to start from say a set of
correlated seeds which may be
distributed to the parties in advance
and that can be locally expanded to be
to the much larger batch of triples and
so this is called a pseudo-random
correlation generator we have some very
recent work which actually should be on
ePrint next week I think where we have a
candidate construction from not quite
lettuces but a variant of ringing LPN we
have some very low handing wait noise
with this arithmetic form again over the
cycle Tomic to power polynomial grain
I think interesting alternative to
speeds and it still seems to have quite
good concrete efficiency but I don't
think it's gonna replace everything I've
talked about today in fact generating
these correlated seats in the first
place actually requires a whole bunch of
triples just to set up the seats maybe
something like the tens of tens of
thousands to create them in the first
place and this is also maybe a good
motivation for doing these one shots or
how much proofs in this setup phase
another thing is this assumption on ring
LPN is not so well studied we're the
first ones to look at this where we
actually rely on having this cyclotomic
room which splits completely into linear
factors
we did a little bit of analysis but so
far it hasn't been looked at much also
it's not on the fly but I should say
this is restricted to the two party
Center so we don't know how to get this
kind of approach to generating speeds
triples with more than two bytes so
Peter it's LP LP n over large fields
with having n yes yes exactly over the
plain Tex ring I see I see
and what does low noise Dracula - like
what's the fraction of corrupted okay so
to be a bit more concrete it means very
very low noise say maybe order of
security parameter I is ideal but this
number of samples is very restricted so
it's like to ring out the N samples
where the the noise has maybe a couple
of hundred nonzero coordinates okay so
that pretty much brings me to the end so
you've seen this tour of the speech
protocol which is at the moment at least
the most practical approach to dishonest
majority MPC and we've looked at how
lattices he used in space we use this
low depth of morphic encryption scheme
with some large parameters mainly due to
those the use of zero noise proofs and
distributed decryption I think these are
the areas which
to see the more interaction with lettuce
community and let's see if people can
come up with anything also be very happy
to collaborate if anyone wants to reach
out most importantly I'm looking forward
to seeing what could come out of this
okay so we have any more questions okay
thank you very much Peter thanks Peter
great talk we we have to Peters today
the peter number two no particular
ordering to peter Rendell will speak in
15 another 20 minutes
so that's 11:00 a.m. Pacific time that's
great thank you